logan is a more or less self-contained
entry in the x-men franchise with
director james mangold saying he set it
in 2029 around five or six years after
the events of Days of Future past to
ensure he didn't have to worry too much
about x-men movie continuity
however Logan still teases numerous
connections to the x-men Cinematic
Universe and dropped some nice Easter
eggs to the comic books - yippee-ki-yay
movie lovers it's Jan here and in this
video I'm going to unpack some of the
best Easter eggs and x-men references in
Hugh Jackman's last movie as Wolverine
I've also got an awesome set of Logan
merchandise to give away including a
t-shirt shot glasses a dog tag bottle
opener and a metal notebook for a chance
to win all you need to do is subscribe
and leave a comment about the Easter
eggs or let me know about any I missed
and for bonus ways to end - check out
the gleam link in the video description
below
quick warning there will be spoilers
ahead if you haven't seen the movie yet
so if that's you check out my spoiler
free review of Logan and come back here
when you've had a chance to see the
movie Wolverines healing factor isn't
working properly in Logan he's aging and
he just doesn't look like the same
Wolverine we're used to seeing in the
x-men movies still there's an amusing
shout-out to Hugh Jackman signature
Wolverine look when the mutant children
trim Logan's succeed while he's asleep
and give him back some of that
distinctive Wolverine look we're used to
from the movies and there's also a fun
little nod to Wolverines love of cigars
when he grabs a handful of them just
before leaving the gas station the
Statue of Liberty which was center stage
during the climactic battle at the end
of the first x-men movie is referenced a
couple of time first via the Liberty
motel where Laura and her guardian
Gabriela Lopez are staying and secondly
during a conversation between Charles
and Logan who discussed the events of
Liberty Island from the first movie
Logan builds on the post-credits scene
from x-men apocalypse where we saw dark
suited men from ethics Corp walk into
the Weapon X facility at alkali Lake to
collect various blood samples being
stored there in Logan is a company
called alkali transition which is taken
up the Weapon X program creating new
young mutants like X 23 the name alkali
transition could be a double reference
to both alkali lake were the Weapon X
program started and transition could it
be a nod to Terrigen mists karagin is a
substance from the comics that when it
was released in
the Earth's atmosphere slowly started
killing off mutants and as a curious
parallel in the movie when Vander Rice
explains how alkali transition
distributed gene therapy through soda
and breakfast cereals to almost
eradicate random mutations writers plan
wasn't to exterminate all mutants
however but to eradicate any mutants
that they didn't develop and control
themselves
Rice's virus like gene therapy could
also provide an explanation for why
Logan's mutant healing factor has been
waning by the ways and arises the lead
scientist responsible for creating x-23
just like he is in the comics and in
Logan we also learned that Wolverine was
responsible for killing Rice's father
which also happened in the comics when
he went berserk ordering his escape from
Weapon X and x-men apocalypse when Logan
flips through transition Case Files at
the hotel we see notes revealing some of
the source DNA for the young mutants
including DNA from Jane Paulus aka Logan
which was used for X 23 another case
file reveals that one of the sources of
DNA is Christopher Bradley you appeared
in x-men origins Wolverine was one of
the original team x members Bradley was
able to control electrical devices but
left the team until he was hunted down
by Sabretooth to retrieve his DNA for
the weapon eleven programs in Logan we
find out that Professor X has gone into
hiding and has to take regular
medication to prevent seizures that can
cause catastrophe all around him and at
one point in the movie a radio report
mentions the Westchester incidents which
occurred here previously in which
various mutants were killed Westchester
is the location of the x-mansion and the
heavy implication that Charles
accidentally lost control of his powers
killing many of the x-men this is a nod
to the old man Logan comic storyline
which Logan loosely adapt where it was
Wolverine who accidentally slaughtered
the x-men after being tricked by the
villain Mysterio by the way there are
some cool visual nods to that comic
series such as this shot of Logan
punching a guy all the way through his
skull with his claws and there's another
picture of Hugh Jackman's Logan looking
grizzled and worn with a couple of chest
wounds which is evocative of his look in
old man Logan another comic book series
which heavily influenced the Logan movie
is death of Wolverine in the comic book
series Wolverine also meets his end as
he rescued a group of mutants that are
being experimented on by dr. Cornelius
Atheneum
of the Weapon X program and in Logan the
young mutants hideout is a location
called Eden a name that has echoes as a
paradise face that loathe and refuse
them from in death of Wolverine death of
Wolverine also features a Logan whose
healing factor has stopped working
properly and where Wolverine uses a
serum on himself at the end of the movie
it's a nod to how he gave the mutants he
rescued in the comics a regenerative
serum by the way some of the mutants at
Logan and x-23 meet up with us
Eden hint towards possible future
x-force members says Rick tore an
original x-force member in the comics
with extremely powerful seismic
abilities which in the movie at one
point he uses against x24 and another
young mutant gideon is an x-force mutant
villain in the comics
although Wolverines comic book Canary
costume was teased in the alternate
ending to James Mangold's movie The
Wolverine we don't actually get to see
it in Logan where it properly would have
felt out of place in terms of the tone
set by the movie it's got a cool Easter
egg to the costume though at the very
end of the movie during Logan's funeral
when one of the mutant children is
holding a Wolverine toy dressed in the
canary costume the costume also appears
earlier via the x-men comics that Logan
finds Laura is reading the x-men comics
that Laura was reading were made
especially for the movie however one of
the issue numbers is 132 which could
point the real comic book uncanny x-men
number 132 where Wolverine meets Don
appeared for the first time as they
fight in that comic Wolverine discovers
Donald Pierce's cybernetic arm which of
course he also has in the Logan movie
and Logan's comments as he flips through
the comics or an interesting bit of
commentary on the status of superheroes
in this part of the x-men universe when
Logan says that maybe a quarter of it
happened and not like this he's
commenting on how he's tired of heroes
being mythologized and turned into
celebrities whose stories are constantly
retold and distorted and it could also
be a little sideswipe at the x-men movie
franchise and how it's become known for
messing around with the timelines which
end up wiping away the events of the
whole movie trilogy and introducing new
continuity problems at the same time
nevertheless Logan still includes a
little homage to how Fox like to
sprinkle X symbols into the x-men movies
when Laura turns across and Wolverines
grave onto its side so it resembles
x-man goals Logan also channels several
non superhero movies a couple a
particular note of the road movie Little
Miss Sunshine starring Abigail Breslin
and the 1953 Western Shane's which
features a gunslinger hero who wants to
leave his past behind
Shane gets various shout outs in the
movie and it's clear that Mangal feels a
real connection between the story of
Shane and the legend of Logan including
Logan's desire for a simple life and
weariness with his life as a hero as
well as the effect violence has had on
Logan's life and the lives of those he
loves by the way at one point in the
movie we see Wolverines dog tags that he
was given an x-men origins Wolverine
just before undergoing the adamantium
bonding procedure
Wolverine actually tossed his dog tags
away at the end of x-men 2 when he
abandoned Stryker next the collapsing
dammit alkali lake those dog tags would
have been washed away at the end of
x-men - so how hovering has them in
Logan is presumably because he changed
the timeline in Days of Future past or
they're simply a different version of
those tags and as a nod to James
Mangold's the Wolverine movie via a
samurai sword that you can spot in Logan
and Caliban home it could be the same
katana that Yashida gives Logan in that
movie after he saved him during the
bombing of Nagasaki in World War two or
it could be a similar samurai sword that
hints the Wolverines connection to Japan
and samurai culture now what other
Easter eggs and references did you spot
in Logan and what was your favorite
moment or Easter egg from the movie
don't forget to leave a comment and
subscribe for your chance to win this
awesome pack of Logan merchandise and if
you enjoyed this video do please like
and share the video with your friends
coming shortly I'll have another Logan
video looking at some of the scenes and
things that didn't make it into the
final movie so be sure to turn on your
notifications so you don't miss that
video and you can tap or click here for
more videos you might like thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers